i think for me it was having a deeper
understanding of like energy
having a deeper understanding and this
is what noel really helped me with
was just constantly clearing my energy
centers clearing my chakras making sure
that they were
spinning moving in the right direction
and and i had been through
so many surgeries that she said that's
one of the
things where because when you're when
you have certain when you're under
surgery
and you're under anesthesia you are so
wide open like your physical body but
also your energetic body is so
wide open and there's a lot of you know
we call we call you know when you talk
about attachments i'm sure you're
familiar and
in chords for example like energetic
cores you do another
same oh yeah and so there was so much of
that
that we had not cleared because until
you're in a space where you
understand that those those cores need
to be removed
that you need to be in your sovereign
space and
so much of that had happened and i had
no idea because
when you're understood you're so
vulnerable and you're so open
and you're also under a lot of
medication which also takes
you it kind of like blocks your
intuition a bit
right um and your third eye and so sh
there was so much clearing
that she had to do in that process in
that eight months and so she would talk
to me
like we would go through like a list of
all the things that she had cleared
and were it like where in my body so
were
my energetic center but also were my
physical body
and the the where where there were
blocks that she cleared there was also
physical manifestations of those blocks
and so when she so you can have pains in
different areas of your body
um let's say you know what let's say we
have about you i'm sure you're probably
familiar with like the seven chakras it
was more than seven chakras but we focus
on the seven because it's easier
um and let's say like you have your
sacral right your root you're saying
when you feel
ungrounded that's your root chakra um
you might need some
you might need clearing there or just
support and then you can feel more
grounded
with your sacral that's your your
adrenals your reproductive organs your
intimacy your sexuality all of that and
so
when those energy centers are either
imbalanced not in alignment blocked
maybe spinning in the wrong direction
it affects that part of you
physiologically
right and so there are areas in my body
that you know it seemed like
conventional healing traditional healing
with medicine
that physical therapy was not healing
and
working with noel and clearing blocks in
my
energy centers allowed those areas of my
body to have more flow
um and and it and heal and so then i
realized
okay everyone has like a different
vehicle
right and i thought and i realized our
energy centers are in alignment
with our physical organ systems
and so it made so much sense to me to
like if
i'm i'm getting so woo here is that okay
oh i'm
i'm i am literally as woo as you could
imagine so
every word you're saying and i'll pause
and ask for clarification
when i feel like it's it's something
where we'll lose people
okay okay amazing then um so anyway i
just kind of i felt like you know
everything is energy right when
whether or not you're doing reiki or
prana you know people are always asking
me
what's reiki and i say okay reiki is a
japanese technique where you're
channeling you know you're you're almost
like a conduit and you're you're
in your kind of directing energy
specific area place person thing
but really like we're all energetic
beings so really we all can do that
and there's techniques and there's
styles and there's different names for
it but essentially when you send love
that is the same thing you know when you
think about someone that you love and
you hold them in your heart you're
sending them love is the same thing
so then i thought about the vibration of
food
and how whole foods have this powerful
energy like from the earth
and so and so i just thought like
well what if i tried putting energy back
into my body
through food because it just made sense
to me like already with the science of
it
and so so i was just kind of trying that
on my you know with my own body as i was
in that recovery process
and then just decided to try it with
with clients as well just to see
like and and just and also adding an
intentionality to it
um and adding in a level of like
mindfulness and gratitude and seeing
how they would receive the food back
into their body because
when i teach people to have like to just
take a moment i walk them through like a
gratitude
process say at the beginning of the day
and then we take that energy
we put it back into the food we put into
our body just doing that in and of
itself
takes your body if you happen to be in a
sympathetic state
into a parasympathetic state and then
now your digestive system
is in a space where it can receive
because it's like calm
and relaxed and even that like from a
physiological place
allows your body to process better
digest better
absorb the nutrients better and so it
just
it just kind of all made sense to me
like once i started trying it
and for anyone where they feel like it
might be a little woo
or you know a little rubbish i'm just
like doesn't cost you anything
you don't need me i'll show you how to
do it you
do it and see and see how that feels in
your body as you receive it like
see how the food tastes and in its most
simplistic form
right we talk about we talk about food
as you know and
like love is that secret ingredient you
know we talk about like
like the recipes from our mom or our
grandmother and how we can replicate it
to the t
that that they wrote down but it might
not taste the same
like why is that is even if we use all
the same brands
everything is it really because grandma
left out a secret ingredient
she didn't want us to know about it's
really the energy
that comes through her and it's and it's
powerful
and when we talk about quantum and
resonance if you're going to add that
part in it it kind of makes sense